LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live as I/O
from Moscone Center here
in San Francisco.
I'm Louis Gray from Google
Developers Live.
I'm joined today by Baris
Gultekin, who's working on
Google Now.
Welcome, sir.
BARIS GULTEKIN: Hi.
Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: And you're the
Director of Product Management
in the search team focused
on Google Now.
Google Now has really been
incredible, I think a
revolution, in search.
To have the card-based
capability and some of the
automation that you're doing
and really trying to
anticipate what it is a user's
looking for and tell them just
at the right time.
So I know we have a good chunk
of time to talk it today at
GDL at I/O. Thank you
for joining me.
Maybe you can give us a little
bit of background on the
project and how it came to be.
BARIS GULTEKIN: Sounds great.
Thank you.
It's exciting to be here.
I have a few slides that I'd
like to go through to just
talk about Google Now.
Let me just dive right in.
LOUIS GRAY: Go ahead.
We'll jump in the slide deck
and have a conversation.
BARIS GULTEKIN: Sounds good.
So we started Google Now to
help you at just the right
time by giving you the
information right
when you need it.
But before I start and talk
about Google Now, I think it
helps to think about how Search
has evolved over time
to lead us to where
we are now.
We started in 1998 with the
concept of keywords.
And when users type in a
keyword, our users were
delighted to find all of these
links, the ten blue
links on the web.
But of course immediately they
started asking for more.
So we started adding things like
images and videos so they
get a much richer
experience when
they search for something.
And recently we announced
the Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph is our
ability to understand
semantically about things,
places, and people, and the
relationships between them.
So we can answer questions
directly and
in a lot more detail.
And of course, afterwards
came Mobile.
With Mobile, it's really,
really important that we
understand conversation.
And it's really important
that we
understand natural language.
So that's what we focused on.
And then we launched it
as part of Google Now.
If you think about both of these
directions, it's all
about giving you the right
answer really fast, when you
need it, especially with Mobile,
giving you the answer
fast, right away is
very important.
And Google Now is a great
evolution into this next step.
It gives you the information you
need before you even ask.
So think about it as trying to
understand your context and
giving you the information
that's right
relevant for that context.
So we think about Google Now as
a way to give you just the
right information at just
the right time.
It's supposed to be
very contextual.
And if you take a step back it
really fits in well with what
we want to do in Google.
At Google we want computers to
do all the hard work so you
can focus on what matters
to you most.
Google Now embraces that and
tries to use the power of
Google with thousands of
computers and also have this
powerful machine that's very
contextual, your phone, that
you have a personal relationship
with, and combine
the two to give you the
information you need at just
the right time.
So it helps to have users walk
through a day of life in
Google to even visualize
what Google Now does.
And the first step is
Google Now helps you
organize your day.
So imagine that you woke up in
the morning and you're sipping
your coffee.
Chances are you care about what
to wear that day and you
care about the weather.
So we'll just have the
weather ready so you
know what to wear.
And if you need an umbrella,
you can take the
umbrella with you.
As you're getting ready to leave
home, we'll tell you
about traffic.
Chances are you care about
traffic, of course.
And you know that you need to
leave a little early if
there's traffic on
your way to work.
And when you get to work, the
types of things you care about
are "when my next meeting is."
So we'll make sure that we
tell you when your next meeting
is and tell you that
you need to leave now
so you're not late.
We don't want our users
to be late, ever.
So we're very proactive about
telling our users--
taking into account where they
are and where they need to go
and taking into account
the traffic.
We also want to make sure
that we remove friction.
As you're going through your
day, there's a lot of
different things that you
have to worry about.
And we want to make sure that we
assist the users when they
need assistance the most.
And travel is one such case.
When users start traveling,
they need a lot of
information.
They'd like to get a lot of
suggestions for their travel.
So Google Now is a great
assistant for travel, as well.
For instance, when you're
traveling and you're waiting
for the train to come, we'll
tell you that, "here's the
next train, it's arriving in
five minutes." So you know
that you need to hurry up a
little bit to get to your
destination.
Or when you arrive at your
airport, we'll have your
flight status so that you can
take your time and grab a bite
before you get to your gate.
We'll also have your boarding
pass ready.
And when you take that flight
and land at your destination,
we'll help you get
to your hotel.
So that's one less thing
to worry about.
Another thing that we really
want to do is we want to help
you discover new things,
as well.
So for instance, when you're
at a symphony with a loved
one, and your mind is back at
home about the sports team
that you care about,
we'll keep you
updated about live sports.
And when you're traveling and
you are wandering around, we
want to make sure that you don't
miss that cool photo
spot that everyone's
taking pictures at.
So we'll show you where
that photo spot is.
And as you're getting ready for
the weekend, we also want
to help you find cool things
to do for Saturday evening.
We'll show you comedy shows
or concerts that weekend.
So that's broadly what
Google Now does.
It's very contextual.
It tries to understand what you
need and try to provide
you the information before
you even ask.
LOUIS GRAY: Having looked at the
keynote today, we looked
at Amit and some of his vision--
he called it the
"Star Trek Computer"--
to bring on the future of Search
and getting the content
to you at the right place,
at the right time.
And some of the words he talked
about was "assist", and
really trying to find the next
step, to be able to get it to
you exactly when you need it.
I had this interesting
experience when Google Now
first came out.
It's been about a year.
And I remember I was at home one
Saturday in the middle the
day and my phone buzzed.
And it said, "you need to leave
right now to get to--"
and at the time, it called it
"unknown location." And it
said, "you have 25 minutes." And
I looked and I said, what
are you talking about?
And I realized every Saturday
around that time I had gotten
in my car and driven to take my
kids to baseball practice.
And somehow Google knew this.
And it alerted me, without my
having to tell it anything,
that I should go immediately
if I'm going
to get there on-time.
Because I always go on Saturday
at that time.
And that was my aha moment that
Google Now was really
impressive.
From a geeky perspective,
we call it
Persistent Implicit Search.
It's constantly searching
for you.
And you might not explicitly
tell it what you want but it's
always looking on your behalf to
find you the right content
at the right time.
And so what is your view
on that, in terms of
the future of Search?
How is Now kicking that off?
BARIS GULTEKIN: So we
have all of this--
you have all of this
interaction
with your phone, right?
You carry it with you
everywhere you go.
But yet, it's very, very
important for us to understand
that and then help you at
just the right time.
In your case, for instance,
being able to tell you that,
hey, there's traffic, you should
leave now, because
you're always there at the
time is the aha moment.
For a lot of our users, things
like when they search for a
restaurant to go to and then
they hop into their car and
the directions to that
restaurant is right there.
These little things are these
magic moments that our users
really love.
If that answers your question.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, absolutely.
And one thing, you talk about
people now, originally, it was
all on Mobile.
And this really--
having Glass, it's been a really
impressive thing to
find the content, exactly what
you want, with just a swipe of
the finger.
But we saw some really
incredible
additions today, to Search.
And maybe you can talk to me a
little bit about how some of
that Voice Search is coming to
either Chrome on the desktop,
but as well as the new cars that
came out at Google I/O.
BARIS GULTEKIN: So the Voice
Search coming into Chrome is
quite exciting.
We announced that with what
we call the "hot word".
You can start talking to your
desktop or laptop right away.
All you need to do is, when
you're on google.com, just
say, "OK, Google," and
start speaking what
you'd like to get.
We think that's really,
really exciting.
And it's, again, in that
evolution, where the Star Trek
computer is slowly
becoming real.
You need to be able to talk to
your computer and have it do
things for you.
So we think that's really
exciting, basically bringing
the power that we have with
our devices to also other
platforms, like the laptop
and the desktop.
In addition to that, we also
announced that we're going to
have Reminders on Google Now,
which I'm really, really
excited about.
We want our users to rely on
Google when they need to be
reminded of things.
So if you are going to--
if you need to remember to buy
eggs when you go to Safeway,
all you need to do is just say,
"remind me to buy eggs at
Safeway." And the reminder will
be there contextually,
right at the right time.
LOUIS GRAY: So when I get next
to Safeway, it'll say "hey,
buy eggs?"
BARIS GULTEKIN: When you're at
Safeway, it'll say, "hey, buy
eggs." Also, because Google Now
semantically understands
the locations that you care
about, you can also say things
like, remind me when I'm at
home to do something, or,
remind me when I get to work
to talk to my colleague.
So it's basically time-based
reminders and
location-based reminders.
Another thing that's really,
really important is that we're
also enabling an integration
of reminders in your search
experience.
So let's say you're searching
for a movie that's upcoming.
On the Knowledge Graph, you'll
be able to see a button that
says, "remind me when this movie
comes out." And it'll
remind you when that happens.
Or when you are searching for
a date, "when are Oscars?"
When you see that date, also
you'll have a reminder to be
reminded when that becomes
available.
LOUIS GRAY: I think one of the
things we talked about was
that Google Now really
started as a 20%
project here at Google.
For those who are a little
familiar with Google's
culture, that's when an employee
essentially dedicates
one day of his or her week to
a new project and focuses on
it all the time.
And what that really means is
usually an employee has a
full-time job and another
job, which is the 20%.
Can you take me through that?
How did that become a 20%
project of yours and then
consume you fully?
BARIS GULTEKIN: Absolutely.
It's really exciting.
Even though we're betting really
big on Google Now, it's
had its humble beginnings as
a 20% project, as you said.
It started when our engineering
lead was thinking
about, how do you make sense of
the location information?
And then he launched the
location history analysis and
basically understanding that we
show our users, here's how
much time you spend at home and
at work, and here are the
places that you go
to frequently.
Then we gathered a group of
engineers, volunteers,
volunteering their time
in addition to
their full-time job.
And we started putting
demos together.
These demos got our executives
really excited.
And when we went to our
executives and said, hey,
here's something we have.
They were so excited that they
said, great, launch it in a
few months, we have
I/O coming.
And the rest is history.
We launched it in four months.
And the reception
has been great.
LOUIS GRAY: We are coming
up on that one year.
It's amazing to think
that it only
launched at I/O last year.
To me, it felt like we've
always had it.
I've been an Android user.
We've always had the cards.
It's really easy to kind of look
and see what the sports
scores are.
And it learned really quickly.
It says, hey, this guy likes--
I like the A's, you like
the Giants, we
can still be friends.
You still get to see that
content, sports scores, and
the stocks, and the news,
and the whether.
It's been really interesting
to see that kind of
recommendation pop through, and
get exactly what you want.
Now I/O is a developer
conference.
So I'm going to ask you a
geeky question again.
You look at this--
you've really got to pull from
a lot of different places.
You talked about location
history being the first one.
So you've got to pull from the
Directions API, Calendar API,
Google Translate API.
How did you go about looking at
all of these different APIs
to make one cohesive service?
And did having those APIs in
play make it a lot easier and
a lot faster to ship?
You only had four months.
BARIS GULTEKIN: Absolutely,
yes.
So we have a huge benefit of
sitting on top of all of the
Google services that our users
use and love every day.
So when we started, we rely on
a lot of core services that
Google has, Location is one of
them, but also the Calendar,
email, and the searches
that you have.
So we have the benefit of all of
these teams thinking really
hard about those instances when
users use those products.
And what we do is we bring
information from those
products to the user proactively
at the right time.
So we did have a lot of benefit
from all of those
API's that are available
to us.
LOUIS GRAY: And I think, what I
saw at Google Now, you look
at today's keynote.
And a lot of it was about having
the same environment on
desktop, on Mobile, on tablet.
Android introduced the
capability to dismiss
notifications across each
of these devices.
Is that something where
we're really
looking at having a unique--
sorry, a similar interface on
each of these devices, as well
as Google Now?
BARIS GULTEKIN: That's right.
So we announced the availability
of Google Now on
iOS, iPhone, and
iPad recently.
So we want to make sure that we
bring our services to where
our users are, regardless
of the platform.
So starting with Android, we
brought it to iOS, and now
part of it is also available
on the desktop.
So we want to make sure that our
users to get the best of
Google, regardless of
where they are.
LOUIS GRAY: Now I'm going to
bring up the Giants one more
time, but in a different way.
So a few months out of the year,
I'm intensely interested
in a couple sports teams,
because I'll
play fantasy football.
And so I'll find myself
constantly checking on the
scores for the Washington
Redskins and the New York
Giants, because I've got a
couple of their players.
And after that, I don't care.
And so, how easy is it for
somebody to dismiss something
where Google Now infers an
interest, but it might be a
temporal interest.
What kind of information can
they do to help teach Google
Now and make it better?
BARIS GULTEKIN: So we
do various things.
We try to understand the
likelihood that you're
interested in something.
So things like time decay,
for instance.
The last time you were doing a
search and you were engaging
with the A's or Giants.
If it has been a long time since
you've engaged, then
we'll take that into account in
understanding whether you
care about seeing that
information.
There's also things you can do
like dismisses for instance.
You'll learn from
your dismisses.
We give a lot of control
to our users.
So they can also tweak the cards
that they're seeing.
They can add more
sports teams.
They can remove sports teams.
So all of those in combination
are the things.
Either implicitly we try to
understand that that was
temporal, or explicitly you
can teach the system by
dismisses or by saying, no,
I don't want this anymore.
LOUIS GRAY: Is there
a Google Now API?
Is there a way for developers
to tap into that and make
their own custom cards?
Or ways for the applications
to interface with that?
BARIS GULTEKIN: So we have a
couple of partnerships that
are already live.
For instance, with United
Airlines, when you check in,
you'll have your boarding
pass ready when you
arrive at the airport.
Or when you purchase a ticket
with Fandango, that ticket
will be ready when you arrive
at the movie theater.
We also have a partnership
with Zillow.
So if you're in the market for
a home, we'll show the open
houses in the area
you're looking.
In addition to all of this,
today we are also announcing
that, with our select partners,
they can mark up
their emails so we understand
whenever there's a flight or
whenever they have a hotel
or reservation coming up.
So all of those are ways where
we engage with our partners to
provide more information into
Google to show to their users.
LOUIS GRAY: So what type of
information goes into Google
Now to improve recommendations?
You've talked about location.
You've talked about possibly
search history.
But what else does Google take
from the different pieces that
you're watching on a mobile
phone to make your cards even
more smart?
BARIS GULTEKIN: So location's
a core component.
We want to be able to help you
get to your next destination
and tell you traffic about it.
So location becomes a very core
component of Google Now.
Searches are quite important.
We'd like to help you continue
researching or we'd like to
help you get to your next
destination because you've
been researching that place.
So Search is another
component.
Calendar is really important
because with Calendar, you're
explicitly saying, I have this
meeting that I need to get to.
So there are many things that
we can help with that
experience.
So we focus on that, as well.
At large, what we try to do is
we try to think about, what
are the instances in which
our users need
assistance the most?
And could we predict and help
in those instances?
And prioritize that way.
LOUIS GRAY: So I
had an incident
recently when I was traveling.
I flew over to Paris.
And I open up my phone, and
first time I get Wi-Fi access,
I look at my new cards.
And it was really incredible
to see how not only did the
phone know what I was doing,
but it had all
this helpful stuff.
And I know your demo basically
talked about
places to take photos.
And for me, I'm not really
huge photographer.
But I appreciate knowing that.
But it had stuff like
conversions.
It would say how many dollars
a euro is and other bits.
What are the things that
play into travel?
What kind of really cool cards
can come up when I travel
3,000 miles?
BARIS GULTEKIN: So when you
travel, there are a couple of
things we show.
We show your time at home
so you know when
to call back home.
We'll tell you things like
conversion rates, the currency
conversion rates.
We'll give you information about
translation, so you have
a translation tool at
your fingertips.
We'll also show you
attractions if
you're new to that city.
If you've been to that city
multiple times, chances are
you don't care about attractions
anymore, so we
won't show it.
LOUIS GRAY: How many times
is a number of times?
Is three a lot?
Is five a lot?
BARIS GULTEKIN: Five
is probably a lot.
The way we try to think about it
is, is showing this card to
the user adding value?
And if you've been to a place
five times, if you've been to
London five times, for instance,
showing you, hey,
there's Big Ben, doesn't
really matter anymore.
So we stop showing it.
We also want to make sure that
throughout the process of
traveling, we help with
various things.
For instance, if you were
searching on Google a week
before you go there about
getting to a destination, for
instance, a restaurant that
you're going to meet your
friend at, we'll show you
directions to that place when
you're there.
So it's basically a collection
of things that we want to help
you manage your day-to-day life
as well as little tools
that will also help with
the experience.
In addition to helping you
discover new content, like
photo spots nearby,
or attractions.
LOUIS GRAY: We talked a little
bit about the genesis of the
product as a 20%.
So I'm really intrigued by the
amount of content that is
flowing through mobile devices,
the amount of mobile
web tracking that's happening,
the amount of mobile web
browsing that's occurring.
Would this project even have
made sense in a world without
smartphones?
Would it even have happened?
What were those trigger
points that says, aha,
we've got to do this.
BARIS GULTEKIN: I think
Mobile is critical.
Because people--
Mobile, first of all, it's
a very contextual device.
It has location in it.
It's also connected and it's
with you all the time.
Another aspect of Mobile is
that users have this very
personal connection with
their devices.
They're constantly using
their device.
I think Mobile is key in helping
us understand what
your context is, in helping us
understand in what situations
you need this type
of information.
So without Mobile, I think this
product would have been
much less powerful.
LOUIS GRAY: Do you find
sometimes that people confuse
Google Now with Voice Search
and they'll ask
you one or the other?
Do you see them as being
completely intertwined?
BARIS GULTEKIN: I think the
whole Search experience--
we think of that [INAUDIBLE]
as a whole.
So Google Now is part of the
Google Search app on Android
as well as on the iPhone.
You can search with
your keyboard.
You can also do a Voice query
and it will assist you with
that query.
And it will also try to infer
what your search is and try to
show you information.
So I see all of this as a
collective assistant trying to
help you, either before you
ask or when you ask.
We want to make sure that
we have the best
experience for you.
LOUIS GRAY: You put out a
keyword, which is "assist."
There's assist, and there's
anticipate.
Anticipating what you're going
to ask before you even ask it.
Going back to Voice Search,
I'm a parent.
I've got three kids that
are five and under.
And for them, every screen
should have everything in the
world available.
They can't believe it
if they can't find
exactly what they want.
And I'll often run into my
daughter holding up a Nexus 7
tablet to her face and saying,
Google, show me
videos of sea turtles.
And if it doesn't load, like if
there's a problem with the
[INAUDIBLE], she's like, Google,
show me videos of sea
turtles, until they all come
up and she's on her way.
And so it's just been--
you look at the evolution of
it and the fact that we're
able to take all of these things
for granted, to be
right there.
It's just stunning.
And I look at Google Now, with
its cards, and the fact that
it is only a year old, and
how far we've come.
It's been really incredible
to watch.
I definitely appreciate you
coming on the GDL at I/O stage
to talk about it.
And I hope we can see really
incredible stuff for year two,
when we definitely will
be bringing you back.
BARIS GULTEKIN: I can't wait.
We believe the potential is so
high and we're just starting,
so, looking forward to it.
LOUIS GRAY: So definitely, thank
you for taking all the
time with me, Baris, I really
appreciate that.
For those of you on the live
stream, if you want to see
great GDL content the rest of
the year, subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube
and check out
developers.google.com/live.
We'll be back here at
4:30 talking about
performance on Chrome.